>>These students are
investigating a murder mystery.
It's one of several projects
developed by educators
from Whitfield County
in northwest Georgia,
as they transition their schools
to project based learning.
The process began two years
before when Whitfield teachers
and administrators
visited High Tech High.
The San Diego charter school
specializes in project based learning
and hosts workshops to
showcase its methods.
>>Rob: So projects are key to
our effort to serve a diversity
of students within each classroom.
>>Narrator: Inspired by their visit,
Whitfield educators launched their
own project based learning initiative
just a few months later, beginning
with the sixth and ninth grades.
>>We were so excited,
because it was like a tool
that we could give to teachers.
It was like the vision that we saw
for our school and for our students.
>>What we did, we looked at
their core design principles,
a common intellectual
mission, personalization,
adult world connections, and we
said, "Are those good for our kids?"
Well, yeah.
Yeah, they are.
They are good for our kids.
That's not a High Tech High thing.
That's an every kid thing.
>>We'll look at some of the--
>>A group of Whitfield
teachers worked together
to design projects integrating
a variety of subjects,
including history, math
and forensic science.
>>What we're studying now in
genetics is DNA and fingerprinting.
>>Now looking at these, you
should be able to tell me
about what degree they are.
Remember--
>>I remember thinking
back when I used to teach
in a more traditional format, it
seemed to be me versus the kids.
I gave you work.
You don't like it.
You're mad at me.
You know, you give it back.
I don't like it.
I'm mad at you.
It was very adversarial.
It was amazing.
Once we started giving kids work
that was different, that allowed them
to put their passion into it,
to collaborate with others.
All of a sudden, the conversation
between teachers and
students changed.
>>There are three major factors
that help these teachers rise
to the challenge of transitioning
to project based learning.
One is collaborative planning time.
>>That's just the beauty of it,
because we've got a few minutes
in the morning to plan, but once a
month, we all get together and plan
and work together as colleagues.
And you don't have to design it all.
Everybody takes their own part
and contributes what their
strength is toward this big puzzle
of a project.
>>A second critical factor is freedom
to experiment and even to fail.
>>I think a lot of teachers have
the feeling that they are allowed
to fail, and I think that's mainly
because they're really responsible,
not necessarily to
the administration,
but more to each other, and I think
that's a really powerful thing.
>>If I fail to completely organize
a project from the beginning,
it's gonna be a flop
and I know that now.
I know that I can't wake up
and wing it from day to day.
I can't do that.
>>The third factor is remembering
that not every lesson
has to be a project.
>>We at North Whitfield had to stop.
You know, halfway through the
year, you can get carried away
with how a project works and really,
it's about, are the kids learning?
>>So I think it's supporting them
and saying, "Whatever is best
for your students, keep searching,
keep seeking, keep designing."
>>Continued mentoring
and free resources
from High Tech High also
help keep them on track.
>> Have your teachers
present as well.
>>Yes. I think that
would be a good idea.
>>We could do a focused,
everyone together,
and then break out into workshop?
>>It's a little nerve
wracking at first,
but adult like conversation
we're having
with kids now, that's worth it all.
>>Oh wow.
>>It's very, very different.
>>It used to just be a lot of tests,
a lot of, "I'm gonna teach you this,"
and then just spit it back out
on a test paper afterwards.
But now it's more of, "I'm gonna
teacher you this and you have
to produce something that's
actually meaningful from it."
And it actually, it's more engaging
and it makes you actually
want to learn.
>>And what's that for?
>>This is our way of learning.
We're learning how to build, putting
math and science and everything
into our outdoor classroom to learn.
>>I like it.
>>With the growing support
of teachers and students,
Whitfield County plans to continue
implementing project based learning
across the district.
>>I watch students
up and moving around.
They're building something.
They're talking to the students.
They're presenting their work.
They have something great they're
fixing to home to show their parents.
I mean, those are just awesome
things, to watch the kids be engaged.
It's just a fantastic
thing as a principal.